you know when the fbi does a raid
um they already probably have a pretty
good case
and a a pretty substantive suspicion
about wrongdoing that has taken place
the fbi has raided the home
of radical republican congresswoman
lauren bobert's ex-campaign manager
this is not
a good sign for lauren lauren bober
um let's read this article from salon by
igor derish the fbi on tuesday raided
the home of a colorado election clerk
and three others in an investigation
uh-oh into a voting system security
breach
mesa county clerk tina peters a
republican was accused by state
officials in august of helping to leak
voting system passwords to a right-wing
blog i thought the left was doing the
voter fraud peters later appeared at my
pillow ceo mike lindell's conspiracy
laden laden cyber symposium or sibosium
as mike pillow refers to it where the
pillow magnate promised but failed to
produce evidence of election rigging
peters later briefly went into hiding
with lindel's help amid fbi scrutiny we
covered that when it happened you might
remember i we did the story mike pillow
is helping to hide
um an official
accused of tampering so that that's this
individual on tuesday morning the fbi
and local prosecutors raided peter's
home we executed four federally court
authorized operations today to gather
evidence in connection with the
investigation
we did so with assistance from the da's
office from the 21st judicial district
the attorney general's office and the
fbi said district attorney dan
rubinstein
yes dan rubenstein and yes there are
already anti-semitic comments on the the
fact that this took place if you find
that if you look online at the comments
not encouraging you to do it but you can
peters is on is an interview in an
interview on lindell's online streaming
channel said the raid left her quote
terrified
the fbi also raided a home in garfield
county
lindell said one of the homes raided
belongs to sharona bishop a garfield
county resident who served as lauren
bobert's campaign manager bishop has
been one of peter's most prominent
allies in stoking unfounded allegations
of voting machine problems in the
election and hinted at a rally last
month that she was privy to unreleased
data from mesa county
um
this is every every element of this is
absolutely crazy
uh the fbi raided my home as of 6am this
morning accusing me of committing a
crime they raided the homes of my
friends mostly older women i was
terrified they used a battering ram to
destroy one of her friend's front doors
they took all my electronics they were
soldiers in combat gear not men in suits
with badges they looked like they were
in a combat zone
uh man you know the same it's so funny
because we've been against no knock
warrants for so long
um for not particu
obviously for non-violent offenses and
then beyond that we can have a
conversation these folks have been for
no knock warrants forever and now all of
a sudden they're saying they're coming
in like it's a war zone yes
that's what we've been saying all along
and the allegations in this uh entire
fiasco are pretty wild
they include that the elections clerk
gave out passwords to their systems uh
deliberately ran from the fbi with the
help of mike pillow helping to hide them
but we're supposed to believe it's the
democrats that committed the election
fraud given that this is what's going on
it's crazy it is absolutely crazy and
they probably have something very
serious here and whether it will hit
lauren bobert we just don't know yet but
it very well may
um remember when we talk about the fbi
in recent years raiding people
from the republican party we are aware
of folks who shared internal campaign
materials with russia
we have folks associated with trump who
were subsequently indicted for tax
evasion bank fraud remember michael
cohen uh some of the folks who remain
friendly with donald trump ultimately
received pardons for the things they
were convicted of but when the fbi
starts starts the raids it's not looking
particularly good uh fbi agents don't
tend to go after political staffers
ex-campaign managers etc unless they
have a really serious case already
remember when they some of you might
remember this you may not there was that
congressman jefferson
who uh whose office and uh home were
raided and there were bricks of cash in
the freezer and the fbi already knew
exactly what they were looking for at
the point that the raids start they
already have a lot of information and
that seems to be exactly what is going
on here so do you believe it will
eventually hit lauren beaubert i guess
is the main question i have for you
right now
let me know your thoughts and we're
going to have more coverage of this on
our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show we also maybe tomorrow
maybe monday we'll be announcing the
next viewer town hall the one we did
in october
went wild extremely popular event where
everybody gets to call in and of course
members get priority we'll be announcing
the next one for early december tomorrow
or monday so stay tuned for that we're
going to take a quick break and be right
back
one of our sponsors is shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers ingredients and recipes
for artisan cocktails right to you i've
been having fun using shaker and spoon
to make cocktails at home one of my
favorite is citrus paradisi great blend
of vodka tonic lime green tea and rose
rose
you open up the box the whole
presentation is awesome they've got all
the ingredients except the alcohol and
really easy instructions even if you
know nothing about mixing drinks like me
you're still going to have fun and
create drinks that turn out really well
i've been impressed with the results
i've gotten with the shaker and spoon
recipes you learn a lot about mixing
drinks it's fun to do on a date night
it's a great time and it makes a perfect
gift because you're giving someone a
really cool experience shaker and spoon
is giving you 20 off when you use promo
code pacman at checkout go to
shakerandspoon.com
pacman and the link is down below